they enriched us
that's the headline that's the CNN
Headline quoting a Martha's Vineyard
resident about the 50 illegal aliens who
made it to the vineyard after Florida
Governor Ron DeSantis gave them free
airline tickets to the allegedly
pro-migrant pro-open borders liberal
Enclave
they enriched us but I'm having a little
bit of a hard time believing that
if the migrants enriched Martha's
Vineyard
how come Martha's Vineyard residents
made sure to round them all up and ship
them off to a military base within 44
hours of their arrival
if the illegal aliens brought such
benefit to the vineyard why not let them
stay and keep enriching the community
for months and even years to come
I strongly suspect that the Venezuelans
who made it to Martha's Vineyard would
much rather eat lobster rolls by the
water than languish in a military camp
at Joint Base Cape Cod which is where
the supposedly inclusive liberals sent
them
the Liberals contend that the
Venezuelans could not stay because you
see everyone has left Martha's Vineyard
for the season now that's obviously not
true because there seemed to be plenty
of residents around in the vineyard to
push the migrants onto the buses to get
them away from their precious real
estate
but even if it were true
all the better
then there would be plenty of beautiful
spacious comfortable mansions to house
all of the immigrants in houses that are
supposedly currently sitting empty
either way Martha's Vineyard in
September seems like an ideal place to
host this very small number of migrants
this fraction of an iota of a drop in
the bucket one one hundredth of the
number of illegal aliens who cross our
Southern border every single day one one
hundredth
unfortunately the Martha's Vineyard
liberals felt otherwise
after just under two days of Terror the
coastal Elites have rid their community
of its inconvenient Latinos and now the
libs can return to their posture of
loving all immigrants
from a distance I'm Michael Knowles this
is the Michael Knowles show
[Music]
welcome back to the show my favorite
comment on Friday is from tin weasel who
says Democrats there are millions of
empty homes that can house migrants also
Democrats no no not these homes no no no
we're talking about suburban homes
conservative areas red states don't you
come anywhere near the Vineyard
we are gonna round you guys up and ship
you off to a military Camp within two
days mark my words so say the Libs The
Long Martha's Vineyard nightmare is over
the Liberals can rest easy again it was
a humanitarian crisis that's what they
were saying a a I'm not making this up a
Martha's Vineyard tourism account visit
MV had tweeted out when the handful of
migrants arrived quote to our Island
community here is an update on current
humanitarian crisis on Martha's Vineyard
we thank people for their continued help
big press release here's how we're doing
what's the crisis the crisis is 50
people 50 people is a tour group
50 people is an extended family
50 people is
nothing
compared to not just the United States
not just the illegal immigration problem
it's nothing in Martha's Vineyard you
wouldn't even notice these people the
residents would have noticed them they
don't need all these Venezuelan Stripes
around it's not that's gonna there goes
the neighborhood that's going to bring
down those real estate prices and so
they go into absolute overdrive mode
and it was a political Master Stroke by
Ron DeSantis
because everything happened exactly as
you would think
the the Liberals completely gave away
the game they say 5 000 immigrants into
Texas and Cal and Arizona and the border
states at 5 000 immigrants a day it
doesn't matter who cares two million
illegal immigrants a year it's no big
deal suck it up stop complaining these
are wonderful people they're these are
these are future undocumented Americans
oh no
no oh no there's one in my neighborhood
get out the guns get out call in the
National Guard no we can't oh my gosh
they hold on is that a is that a day
worker no no they're just here to stay
get them out of here get him out give me
a bus ship them off to gitmo just get
them out of my get them out of my
neighborhood
and so they hurry them out I mean not
even two days were these people allowed
to stay in Martha's Vineyard before they
were shipped off to an actual military
camp
and now now that the the crisis is over
the humanitarian crisis they're all
standing around they go
I'm I mean uh yeah I and I sure love
those immigrants oh yeah no I really
love the immigrants they uh they
enriched us yeah yeah the rest of the
headline migrants 44-hour visit leaves
indelible mark on Martha's Vineyard yeah
leaves raised blood pressure at least
leaves pools of sweat where these these
liberal residents were standing
what an indelible Mark no it's not an
indelible mark
an indelible mark would be if the
immigrants had been allowed to stay
had had the wealthy Martha's Vineyard
residents all liberals said hey handful
of Venezuelans you're allowed to stay
here and then they could have stayed and
remained in a community and maybe they
could have talked to one another maybe
they would have gone to the same
restaurants and gone to the same
churches not that the libs on Martha's
Vineyard go to church but they would
have gone to the same Community places
maybe gone to the beach together that
would have been an indelible mark
because they would have brought those
people into their communities but that's
not that's not what the libs want from
immigration I think that the libs some
of the libs sincerely like the idea at
least of immigration
but they like it because then they can
go to the fun little Mexican restaurant
once a month
oh gosh what would America be without
those fun tasty little tacos hi hi
Consuela oh nice to see you too all
right see you next month bye-bye they
like that's what they like about
immigration
they like the idea of immigration
because they get a little flavor you
know it's like going on a vacation they
like to they like to be able to go try
something exotic for a few days and then
come home and not have to deal with
anything else they like to go to the fun
for an exotic restaurant
and then then come home and not have to
deal with anything else that's not
community community is when you bring
people in
and you stay with people in perpetuity
and you make them part of your daily
lives and you bring them into your
schools and you bring them into you have
dinner with them
and you spend time with them and you
speak to them that's not what the
Martha's Vineyard people want from
immigration that's not what the libs
want from immigration
the libs want to flood the country with
immigrants
at the cynical level because it gives
them a major electoral advantage but
even at the idealistic level because it
seems really nice and welcoming and
inclusive they just don't want to
include them they want someone else to
include them
they want to get all the credit for
feeling really nice and welcoming and
give me your poor huddled masses at the
poem at Ellis Island
but they don't want the poor huddled
masses
the poor huddled masses don't get to
come to Martha's Vineyard
they go to your town coincidentally
where they'll give Democrats the biggest
political advantage and where the
immigration will bring Crime and will
bring drugs and will bring rape all this
or and will bring murders and we'll
bring all the sort of things that Donald
Trump got in trouble for saying it will
bring that will happen do you know why
that will happen it's not because the
Venezuelans are just a sort of
genetically criminal people it's because
the only way to illegally immigrate to
the United States is to pay off the
cartels
to pay off some of the most vicious
criminal organizations in the world and
then when they arrive here in the United
States they're all in debt to the
cartels and you know how they pay that
debt off they pay that debt off by
running drugs by prostitution by all
sorts of organized crime
it is it is not possible to tolerate
illegal immigration without
simultaneously encouraging more
organized crime and they sure don't want
that in Martha's Vineyard okay they want
that in Del Rio and they want that in El
Paso and they want that in your town not
in their town
they enriched us do you know what they
really think do you know what the
Liberals actually believe about all of
this when you get them into a private
room and they don't need to be
pretending and they don't need to be
trying to Signal their virtue to
everybody this is what they believe they
accidentally put it in an NBC news
article and then accidentally tweeted it
out
NBC news right here official account
Florida Governor Ron DeSantis sending
Asylum Seekers to Martha's Vineyard is
like quote me taking my trash out and
just driving to different areas where I
live and just throwing my trash there a
founding member of a foundation which
helps refugees says
and then they tag NBC Latino they are
literally comparing the immigrants to
trash that's how they view them
and that's not just how accidentally
some NBC reporter use them that's how
the residents of Martha's Vineyard view
them the residents of Martha's Vineyard
hauled these immigrants out of their
Town much faster than they would haul
their trash out the night before the
truck comes
and for exactly the same reason they
view these people as human trash
they don't want any part of them
they'll for the cameras they'll maybe
give them a little hug probably like one
of those weird awkward hugs you know you
kind of where you don't even lean in
that much but you kind of Pat them on
the back and they say okay get on that
bus bye bye see you later
that's how they actually view them and
then and then we're the bad guys because
we say hey let's not encourage millions
of illegal aliens every year
hey hey maybe maybe a nation needs
borders and maybe these citizens of a
Nation have their right to determine who
gets to come in and stay now we're the
Bad Evil awful guys meanwhile they think
of the the immigrants as trash obviously
it's hypocrisy obviously it's a double
standard none of that matters none of it
matters well imagine if the shoe were on
the other foot imagine the double
standard yeah of course that's true the
takeaway here is not to try to persuade
the Liberals that they're Hypocrites
they know it the Martha's Vineyard
people know that they're Hypocrites deep
down okay the point here the takeaway is
do not let them guilt you do not let
them lay it on thick and make some
completely disingenuous moral argument
about immigration they don't believe any
of it themselves they're just tricking
you they're just tricking you
to to harm yourself politically and to
tolerate an actual unjust action which
is illegal immigration because it
advances their political agenda don't
buy it just throw that out the window
okay because if we destroy all of our
borders if we get rid of everything that
distinguishes us as a country the
country is going to die you're going to
die someday too regardless of what
happens at some point you will die
that's why you need epic will right now
go to epicwell.com use promo code
Knowles the daily wire has been closely
following the tragic death of an actress
earlier this month and however tragic
and shocking the underreported story is
that she died without a will leaving her
son to file court papers to control her
estate do not let this happen to you
it's a nightmare a scenario do you
really want to burden your kids with
this while they're still grieving take
five minutes today set up your will with
epic will a complete will package with
epic will provides you with so much more
than just the protection of your assets
they look at your whole Legacy your
finances your medical wishes your
responsibilities as a parent or
caregiver they bundle your last will
living will Health Care power of
attorney HIPAA release and durable
Financial power of attorney in one easy
package to make sure that your entire
Legacy everything you leave behind is
protected and
they make it incredibly easy and
affordable it only costs 119 bucks for a
single person to create a will and when
you use promo code Knowles you will save
10 percent do yourself and your loved
ones a favor make sure you have a will
in place today go to epicwill.com use
promo code Knowles to save 10 on Epic
Will's complete will package that's
epicwill.com promo code Knowles Ronda
santis especially Greg Abbott as well
they they are getting the credit for
this strategy of bussing and flying the
illegal immigrants to the blue cities
though I got to give credit where credit
is due and it happens to be to a buddy
of mine with whom I host a podcast
Ted Cruz
maybe it's to his political benefit that
the media aren't blaming him for this
but this actually was Ted Cruz's idea
and he's been talking about it on our
verdict show for months now and he
actually introduced legislation to make
this happen as a matter of federal law
so a while ago uh this was last year Ted
Cruz introduced what what he called the
Stop The Surge Act and the stop stop the
surge act would force Joe Biden to open
13 New Ports of entry for for immigrants
and so it wouldn't just be a lot right
along that southern border and all those
little border towns the new ports of
Entry
would include Block Island Rhode Island
Greenwich Connecticut Martha's Vineyard
Cambridge Massachusetts where Harvard is
Governor's Island New York Rehoboth
Beach Delaware that's where Joe Biden is
from Nantucket Newport Scarsdale New
York Palo Alto California with all the
technolibs Yountville California Saint
Helena California and uh North Hero
Vermont which is where Bernie Sanders is
from
so this was his idea uh Cruz tweeted out
in response to the this wonderful new
campaign he said Rehoboth Beach Delaware
next tagged Greg Abbott tagged Ron
DeSantis same thing with Palo Alto same
thing with Nantucket it's a great idea
it's a great idea the reason is this
one I don't think it's particularly
unjust to the migrants
I think giving migrants a free ticket to
the nicest of a voluntary free ticket to
the nicest communities in America the
most beautiful geography and these
lovely coastal towns
I think that's actually kind of a nice
thing I would much rather if I were a
Venezuelan migrant who just traipsed all
the way up through Central America
crossed over the Rio Grande I would much
rather chill on Martha's Vineyard than
in El Paso or Del Rio okay and so I
don't think it's particularly unjust to
the migrants
also the migrants are committing a crime
and they should be arrested and deported
but maybe they get a lobster roll in the
meantime and two you need leverage in
politics
okay this is what
the this is the lesson of this whole
stunt you need leverage in politics you
can complain until you're blue in the
face about how the border states have to
deal with illegal immigration and the
Liberals are encouraging a problem they
don't have to face and you know what the
Liberals are going to say okay
yeah right
totally but it's wrong and it's in
violation of our laws and you can't do
this yeah they can do this they don't
care they have the the Liberals in
Martha's Vineyard or Palo Alto or any of
the other places do could not possibly
care less about the illegal immigration
problem it helps them if anything and
there's no downside to them continuing
to support it unless we start sending
plainfolds and Bus busloads full of
these immigrants
to their towns then all of a sudden it
becomes a political problem
this should not be just one stunt okay
this needs to continue forget about 50 a
day that was the shot across the bow 50
the 50 to to just show up and make a
point that's great and we did make the
point and we showed the libs for the
absolute Hypocrites that they are but
now it's got to be a strategy
you've got to not just freak out a small
Enclave of beach-going bazillionaires
okay you've got to make this a political
problem for Democrats it is it is an
affirmatively good thing to ship these
migrants up to these liberal towns
one because the border cities and towns
should not have to shoulder this
themselves
two I don't I don't I actually think
it's sort of at least on the margins
nicer for the for the immigrants to go
through this experience but three it's
the only way to show Americans not just
the the liberal politicians but they're
liberal constituents what the problem
actually is to impel them to action to
to shut down the Border okay to stop
this Mass migration problem which is
horrible for everybody okay got to keep
it up you can tell the politicians are
getting freaked out Muriel Bowser the
mayor of DC who initially all of them
they said oh this is wonderful we're a
sanctuary City we're GLA actually we're
glad you're sending us migrants yup
that's the right thing to do and then
like seven migrants show up they say
it's too much we don't have the
resources and now now she's going out
she's saying you've got to stop this
Governor DeSantis and Governor Abbott
because DC is not up we're not a border
City
we're not a Border Town we don't have an
infrastructure to handle uh this this
type of a level of immigration to our
city but we will will create a new
normal here in our infrastructure and
have a Humane welcome for people and an
efficient
um you know service provision but we we
don't have the ability we're not Texas
yeah you are now though is the thing
well we're not a Border Town yeah now
you are but we don't have the
infrastructure better build up you
better build it pretty quick it's this
is not like it's a new problem the
illegal immigration problem's been going
on for 50 years since the Democrats
started it since the Democrats
intentionally opened up our border to
flood the country with illegal aliens
half a century ago
more than half a century ago
so yeah it now you should have probably
started to build that infrastructure a
little earlier you just thought you'd
never have to deal with the consequences
of your own actions but now you do
so you are you are a Border Town
good I'm glad she says she's going to
build the infrastructure I'm glad she
says she's going to ramp up the
resources I'm glad she says she's going
to welcome these people with open arms
great wonderful I mean obviously federal
law enforcement should Deport the
illegal aliens
but okay you're at the level of the
mayor you're going to welcome these
people that's great one thing she said
that's not true she said we're not a
Border Town yes you are now you are so
Chicago so is New York so is Los Angeles
so is San Francisco says Palo Altos is
Martha's Vineyard says Nantucket all
these places and more
by the way the the final little cherry
on top to have what a brilliant
political strategy this is
the the one critique is well look it's
just wrong to give these people airplane
tickets and ship them into the interior
of the country when maybe that's not
where they want to go maybe that they
should you shouldn't trick them into
going to Parts on the inside of the
country right that what's wrong is is
this extra step these poor people some
of them come with children some of them
a lot most of them don't come with
children but some of them do it's wrong
to add this extra step of travel for
these migrants except except that Joe
Biden has done the exact same thing and
he hasn't done it for just 50 people to
Martha's Vineyard he's done it
consistently many many of these flights
a lot of this transportation to get the
migrants from the border states when
they stop being totally politically
useful there into places where they are
more politically useful so a reporter
finally asked Korean Jean-Pierre White
House Press Secretary about this and
hold on Joe Biden's done exactly the
same thing at a much larger scale than
DeSantis did how is this different
you said it was essentially no different
than what the federal government has
done in sending you know flights in the
middle of the night that's where it's
characterized it uh you know taking
migrants to various different states do
my response to that
so we are offering Solutions that's what
the Biden Harris Administration has been
doing since day one including on the
first day putting forth a comprehensive
immigration reform to deal with this
issue
we have given DHS record funding we have
advanced policies
what have they done
they do these political stunts they vote
against our funding requests they vote
against policies to fix this broken
system stunts aren't Solutions here
stunts aren't policies we're over we're
over here trying to govern trying to
actually fix a system that has been
broken for some time trying to fix a
system that was decimated by the last
Administration and all we're seeing is
from them is petty and dangerous stunts
this is dangerous they're putting
children's lives at risk they're putting
families lives at risk
you keep talking about what the other
guy is doing
but you did the same thing she never
addresses the actual question which is
hey you guys did the same thing so how
is this different
and her answer is well we're offering
Solutions yeah you're offering the same
solution they are you're just doing it
at a much larger scale and you're
criticizing them for doing it and you're
boasting that you did it it reminds me
of there is a great Exchange in the 2012
Republican Presidential primaries when
Herman Cain was running and he had his
his famous 999 Tax plan this percent
nine percent nine percent nine percent
since the 999 plan and he said it was
going to do all these great things and
during the debate the moderator said you
know Mr Kane
uh we the Bloomberg analysts have looked
at your tax plan and they found out that
it would actually not achieve the things
that you wanted to achieve so uh what's
wrong with their analysis and his answer
was well the problem with that analysis
is that it is incorrect
I just love that answer I'm gonna use it
myself but obviously it is not an answer
because you're not explaining what's
wrong that's what she just did
well the difference is that it's totally
different
the different you know what the
difference is you know what the
difference is the difference is
that their Democrats and we're
Republicans and so when Democrats and
Republicans do the exact same thing it's
good for Democrats it's bad for
Republicans when Democrats do anything
that's good and that's wonderful and
that's compassionate including deporting
illegals within 44 hours and sending
them to a military Camp yeah no that's
wonderful that's compassionate that's
welcoming The Stranger but when
Republicans do anything at all that's
evil that's terrible they're Nazis
they're fascists
this isn't hyperbole is what the is what
the president of the United States is
saying
it's awful it's a threat to our
democracy it's an Insurrection couldn't
possibly be worse
that's the difference difference is not
the action
Biden and DeSantis did the same thing
yeah the difference is who did it
and when Republicans do anything we're
Nazis this is what CNN just said CNN
when covering the the Ron DeSantis
strategy up here he points to the he was
interviewing someone about a new
documentary on the Holocaust and he had
to make the comparison we woke up to the
news this morning that Governor Ron
DeSantis of Florida sent two plane loads
of migrants uh to Martha's Vineyard off
the coast of Massachusetts including
kids and whatnot and I'm not saying this
is not a one for one this is not a
parallel here in any way but it does
address some of the same themes that are
part of this documentary it does when
you when you give illegal immigrants a
free voluntary vacation to Martha's
Vineyard one of the nicest places in the
world pretty much like Auschwitz you
know it's kind of it's just like Hitler
you know because you see Governor
DeSantis drinks water and Hitler drank
water so it's like it's look I'm not
making the comparison I'm just telling
you Ron DeSantis is Hitler but I'm not
comparing the two it's just like
everything I don't like is the Holocaust
you know is but I'm not saying that but
I'm certainly wrongly insinuating it
don't you think don't you think
and what about when the libs deported
all of those migrants it was that like
the Holocaust no that was good
no that was good it was it was just
what's the takeaway
what's the takeaway you know what the
takeaway is it's not hypocrisy so much
for the tolerant life the takeaway is
when these people you invoke Nazism
fascism Hitler racism any of the any of
the isms any it's fake just ignore it
let it go in one ear and out the other
they don't mean it it doesn't mean
anything today anyway just laugh at them
you're it's just like Hitler oh okay all
right there it's Ronald Reagan to Jimmy
Carter there you go again
there you go again with the Hitler talk
now speaking of the authority of the
total state of the Biden capricious Rule
and a whim kind of total state
there is some good news I'm pleased to
announce from the White House
the pandemic
after what two and a half three years of
15 days to slow the spread the longest
15 days ever in recorded history
after all that time the pandemic
is over Mr President first Detroit Auto
Show in three years yeah
is the pandemic over a pandemic is over
we still have a problem with covet we're
still doing a lot of work on it uh it's
but the pandemic is over if you notice
no one's wearing masks everybody seems
to be in pretty good shape and so I
think it's changing and I think this is
a perfect example of it
why is the pandemic over the pandemic is
over because Joe Biden says it is is the
pandemic over because anything has
changed about covid in the last week or
two weeks or six months or a year
no nothing about covet has changed or
frankly even like two years no nothing
has substantially changed the reason the
pandemic is over is because Joe Biden
says so and the Way That We Rule now in
in the total state
is that if Joe Biden tomorrow comes out
and says we've got a pandemic again then
they would all believe it okay
he says look we're not wearing masks Joe
Biden never wore a mask he would
occasionally put one on for the cameras
but very rarely even when he issued his
own mask mandate he would violate it and
his family would violate it constantly
because it was never about covid because
the pandemic such as it was never posed
anywhere near the threat that the libs
told us it did it was just a means of
control
and the pandemic was just part and
parcel of the broader Democrat power
grab and the irony of course is that the
more power they take the more they
ruthlessly suppress the dissent the more
they prattle on about our democracy but
we our current form of government the
shape of the regime is much much closer
to oligarchy than it is to a democracy
American government has never been a
democracy exactly the word democracy
does not appear in the Declaration or
the Constitution when it appears in The
Federalist Papers it has only invoked
negatively it's only criticized and and
invoked with disapproval okay we have a
regime that has parts of certainly a
some democratic representation
especially in the early days and then a
kind of aristocratic element to it for
the aristocratic interests and you see
that especially in the in the Senate and
a representation for the states and then
it's even got a kind of monarchical
aspect too in the strong executive power
in one man so it's a regime that has
different elements okay and over time
that has changed and they took away a
lot of the power of the Senate took away
a lot of the power of the states by
directly electing the Senators that
changes the nature of the regime took
away a lot of the power of the People by
expanding the federal bureaucracy
and now I think the system that we live
under is it was always kind of messy but
I think it's just much much closer to an
oligarchy and then the ruling class the
Democratic party which is the kind of
representative of the broader ruling
class they now tell us that if you even
consider voting for a republican you are
a threat to our democracy so if you've
got an ostensibly two-party system where
it is completely unacceptable and you're
being told this by the government it's
unacceptable to vote for the party out
of power then you don't really have a
two-party system you don't really have
anything even really resembling a
democracy you've got a kind of total
State and what I mean by the total state
is that the the regime ideology
infects everything
okay it's not it's not just that the the
government is over here pushing its own
views but you've still you can still do
what you want in your churches and your
schools and in your Civic associations
that's not it just use the case of LGBT
the government right now is actively
forcing the LGBT ideology on all of the
other ostensibly free institutions
such that if a school doesn't teach LGBT
ideology that school will be punished
that school will lose funding that's
school can be sued by the government if
employers don't Embrace LGBT they will
for sure be taken to court by the
government even churches now that's why
they're trying to pass this federal
marriage bill the federal marriage bill
is effectively would outlaw opposition
to the LGBT ideology for all non-profit
groups including churches that could
lose their tax exempt status and
basically would just destroy the church
and you see this in entertainment if a
movie doesn't toe the line on just use
the example of LGBT that movie will be
heavily suppressed that that movie will
be companies will be anathema that
that's what I mean by the total total
State it's not just some narrow area of
public policy or this you know within
this particular jurisdiction no it's the
whole thing okay and Joe Biden
is saying that that is
that is the Democracy the democracy is
what whatever he and his cronies say
that it is you'll really see this with
the FBI so there's a report out now by
the Washington Times no one is talking
about this the
the uh speaking of Nazis earlier uh Joe
Biden accused of pressuring the FBI to
fabricate extremists and white
supremacist cases this is amazing this
is another example of the nullstradamus
phenomenon I mentioned this on the show
a week or two ago I said the demand for
anti-black racism is much much higher
than the supply and so what what happens
is it's it's not just that we can all
get along and say oh this is great we
don't have all these racial problems in
the country that perhaps we once did or
that we would fear no no what happens is
people just fabricate the the racial
incidents and you see this on campuses
all around the country virtually anytime
there's been a racial hate incident an
anti-black racial hate incident it's
been fabricated by black students
themselves or by left-wing activists I I
ran through a Litany of these the other
day on the show there's a whole list of
them in my book speechless so now we're
seeing this proven proven correct at
least according to the Washington Times
Rank and file FBI agents or accusing the
Biden administration of exaggerating the
threat of white supremacists and
pressuring agents
to cook up domestic terrorist cases
involving racist extremists current and
former FBI agents told the Washington
times that the perceived white
supremacist threat is overblown by the
administration we all knew that here's
the part that's that's really shocking
they said top Bureau officials are
pressuring FBI agents to create domestic
terrorist cases and tag people as white
supremacists to meet internal metrics
you know at the end of the month you got
to watch you got to be a little bit more
careful when you drive why because we
know that police departments very often
have quotas to give out speeding tickets
and you'll notice this that you're more
likely to get a speeding ticket at
certain times of the month and in other
times according to these FBI agents
speaking to the Washington Times it's
the same thing with the feds and and
instead of quotas for speeding tickets
it's quotas for neo-nazis and white
supremacists because they don't exist
the only time they exist is when David
Duke goes on CNN occasionally and they
say there it is here's the Ku Klux Klan
but they're not real okay it's imaginary
put that away with Bigfoot and the
Boogeyman
and this is what the agents say quote
the demand for white supremacy coming
from FBI headquarters vastly outstrips
the supply of white supremacy they must
be listening to this show
the agents obviously speaking on
condition of anonymity we have more
people assigned to investigate white
supremacists then we can actually find
of course and that's why you see so many
FBI hoaxes and so much entrapment and so
much egging on of people to to try to
commit some kind of even vaguely
white flavored crimes you saw it in
Michigan with the Gretchen Whitmer plot
you see you see it all around the
country
they're going to keep doing this
and why do I believe the report yes it's
Anonymous reporting I mean I trust the
Washington Times why do I believe it
because we know that the FBI has been so
politicized over the years we know we
just saw first of all we know the FBI
spied on the Trump campaign illegally we
know the FBI and the doj undermine the
Trump Administration and we know that
the FBI just kicked down the door at
Mar-A-Lago at the request of the
Attorney General mayor Garland at the
order of the Attorney General Merrick
Garland who's a Democrat hack political
appointee by Joe Biden
you can see them them talking about this
the guy the the FBI agents are
complaining about this
the FBI agents they're saying that
they're basically being used as
political tools no question about it
no question about it I really strongly
encourage you to go check out the report
at the Washington Times
because that is a real threat so you
think about all of this the country is
an absolute turmoil on every single
metric Biden is failing he's underwater
not just in terms of his performance but
in terms of popular approval he's
underwater on everything including covet
that's why he's got to say that the
pandemic is over now to try to get that
back in the news
so you think it'd be a slam dunk that we
could beat Joe Biden in 2024 right
but I don't know a lot of Republicans
are cautious about this because we say I
don't know they're probably just going
to rig it I don't know they're probably
going to change all the election rules
again to give themselves an advantage I
don't know they're probably going to do
this they're going to do that
is it in a free and fair election
there is not a single chance that Joe
Biden could win re-election there's no
way he would have to step down someone
else would have to come in
and yet now we don't know because we
don't really have faith in the electoral
system Democrats haven't had faith in
the electoral system for a while or at
the very least they've sought to
undermine it when they lose in 2000 2016
and 2018.
and then when they changed all the rules
last time the Republicans started to say
guys this doesn't seem very fair to me
so what happens now what's going to
happen in 2024 Joe Biden was just asked
on 60 Minutes are you going to run for
re-election and for the first time
he didn't give a clear answer
sir are you committed to running again
or are there certain conditions that
have to be right look if I were to say
to you I'm running again all of a sudden
the whole range of things come into play
that I have requirements I have to
change and move and do in terms of
elections in terms of election loss then
it's much too early to make that kind of
decision I'm a great respecter of fate
and so what I'm doing is I'm doing my
job I'm going to do that job and within
the time frame that makes sense after
this next election cycle here going into
next year making Judgment of what to do
you say that it's much too early to make
that decision I take it the decision has
not been made in your own head look my
intentions I said to begin with is that
I would run again but it's just an
intention but is it a firm decision that
I've run again that remains to be seen
this is the clearest evidence so far
that Joe Biden will not run because he's
using the election laws as an excuse not
to be clear here but I've never heard a
sitting president talk like this so I
look I don't know man I'm a respecter of
Fate we'll see what happens I've got
this soft intention but we'll see and
it's because it's just so obvious the
man can barely form an English sentence
at this point he's such an abject
failure the party doesn't want him to
run they want to put up a different
candidate and this is the clearest
evidence yet if you ask me to bet today
will Joe Biden run in 2024 I would bet
that he will not run in 2024 the only
reason I would hedge that bet is because
there is no one to replace him Kamala
and Pete Buddha judge are complete
non-starters they're going nowhere Gavin
Newsom maybe has a shot but he's even he
is is not a very strong candidate to
replace Joe Biden and it just looks like
such weakness from the Democrats for an
incumbent to choose not to run again
look so incredibly weak that they don't
know what to do the Democrats have all
of this power
but when it comes to actually presenting
their case to the American people they
fail and so now they're sputtering and
they're contradicting themselves they
don't know what to say if you've been
thinking to yourself hey it's been a
while since I've heard from Candace
Owens have I got news for you Candace is
back from maternity leave she's got a
brand new daily wire Plus show Candace
Owens the first show Candace next show
Candace Owens maybe the third show we'll
use her middle name she is fearlessly
exploring topics that the media will not
touch and exposing the corruption and
hypocrisy in news and politics best part
is it's five days a week Monday through
Friday you will not want to miss her
explosive first episode which premiered
last week on daily wire plus trust me
when I say it is huge watch Candace
owens's new show now on daily wire Plus
or listen on Apple podcasts Spotify or
wherever you listen to podcasts
speaking of indecision
there is a bizarre new surgery that is
sweeping plastic surgeon offices around
the country it is not transgenderism
that had been developed really in the
60s and 70s and then the surgeons and
the doctors who developed it realized
that it wasn't actually helping anybody
so they tried to shut it down but the
cat was out of the bag that obviously
has been around for a long time and it's
where you saw off parts of people's
forearms and legs and use it to create a
kind of pale imitation of genitals and
affix it to every younger people and
it's really horrifying it's the stuff of
nightmares and it should all be illegal
no somehow though
there is something even creepier somehow
it's that this phenomenon if you think
you've gotten to the bottom of the
slippery slope and then you just slip
down further there is a new surgery it
is called gender nullification surgery
colloquially referred to as the Ken doll
surgery
this surgery is for patients who
identify as non-binary the surgeries
represent alternatives to the
traditional transgender surgery you know
we're far far afield of anything
resembling normal when when transgender
surgery is the traditional option to the
new crazy one which is the non-binary
surgery so this includes sex
nullification or or where you get to
keep both of them
so I'm not even going to use the terms
they're but they're basically you just
recreate you create a new
a new sex organ but you keep the other
sex organ and or you just erase your sex
organs altogether this uh from Mosaic
care which offers this mutilation quote
we understand that some patients will
not be looking specifically for binary
surgeries for gender diverse expansive
non-binary patients we offer
individualized surgical options examples
include penile preservation oh I
accidentally I guess I am saying the
names vaginoplasty vaginal vaginal
preservation with
metoidioplasty and nullification
guess where this Center is located by
the way I'll give you one it's San
Francisco yes obviously it's San
Francisco
do you know how many adults in America
identify as non-binary
because I thought okay look this should
be illegal doctors take the Hippocratic
Oath first to do no harm uh these quacks
should be in prison or they should be in
psych wards themselves and the poor
people who want to chop off all of their
genitals or to have multiple types of
genitals or whatever these guys
obviously need serious psychological
treatment
and spiritual treatment as well okay but
how many people could it be what a
handful
what a hundred people in the country
maybe if I were to give you my craziest
guess I'd say a thousand people
now according to a UCLA survey
over 1 million Americans identify as
non-binary
one million
that number is only going to grow
because it's a social contagion are all
of those people going to go under the
knife probably not I hope not
but the but the more this contagion
spreads the more people are going to do
it
and what is non-binary the the easiest
way I can explain what non-binary is is
my name is Legion for we are many okay
the easiest way that I could explain
what non-binary is is someone who is
creating multiple personalities in their
own head or who
involuntarily uh senses that the
presence of not of multiple
personalities in their own head and who
at a more basic level
Rejects his own Humanity
because that's what this is men human
beings are male or female in the
beginning God created man both male and
female created he them
sexual difference is at the center of
human life it's at the center of
politics it's obviously at the center of
the family it's at the center of the way
we all live together
to
deny your sex
is to deny your your own humanity and
you see this in an extreme way you see
this in in one way with certain just be
social behaviors when men act like women
when women act like men that is a
relatively
uh modest rejection of their humanity
and their own roles in nature when you
go further and you say I'm a man but I
identify as a woman and maybe
chop off parts of your body and you try
to present yourself as a woman that is a
much further rejection
of your humanity and then when you say I
reject sex all together I am a
non-binary or a gender or whatever that
is
a much much further rejection of your
Humanity you're saying not only do I
reject my actual sex I reject the
concept of sex entirely it's at an even
higher level
so we all agree on that I think pretty
much all of us agree on the transgender
thing but that first part that I said
that's the one that's going to raise the
flags that's what's going to get the
clip at Media Matters that's the one
that ever that even a lot of
conservatives are going to say whoa
there buddy I don't know the weekends
what you're telling me men have certain
roles and obligations in society and
they have to behave in a certain way
oh I don't know
and women have a certain role in society
and they broadly speaking are obligated
to fulfill some of those roles roles
that are different from the roles that
men have
yeah
yeah you you have to if you don't
acknowledge that part you're just gonna
end up at the same place this is why all
this crazy transgender pan gender
non-gender whatever stuff it doesn't
just go back five years it doesn't just
go back even 10 years it doesn't even go
back 20 or 30 years to the beginning of
the gay rights movement it goes back to
feminism because they all feminism gay
rights and the transgender movement all
share the same fundamental premise
namely that men and women are
interchangeable
women the feminist movement says a woman
needs a man like a fish needs a bicycle
the feminist movement says men and women
are basically exactly the same they
might look a little bit different but
and we're going to change that through
fashion but yes men and women are pretty
much identical and that's just not true
men and women are different and
complementary
and when you accept that premise then
you inevitably have to get to not only
gay rights you have to redefine marriage
because if men and women are
interchangeable then of course you need
to redefine marriage to say that two men
in a union is the same as two women in a
union is the same as a man and a woman
and once you do that if you if you're
just following the same premise then
you've got to get to transgenderism
because if men and women are effectively
the same then sure have a little Nip
Tuck or don't doesn't matter call
yourself a woman call yourself a man
there's no difference
so you can't you can't undo the rot by
only going halfway there's no splitting
the baby here you've got to you've got
to rip out that whole premise root and
branch and that requires us it was a
point that I made just the other day on
the show and I made it during a netcon
speech that caused some controversy
I think we need to talk about sex and
transgenderism a little bit differently
okay it's not just you know well a man
has a y chromosome and women have two X
chromosomes and that's that you know a
man has this body part A woman has this
body part no it's not just at the level
of the body it's at the level of the
Soul as well we actually have to accept
or at least understand what the libs
you're talking about when they talk
about gender expression yeah gender
expression is real it's true men can act
like girls girls can act like boys
you just shouldn't because you have
duties and obligations and to get back
to the veto Corleone Don Corleone Johnny
fontaine's standard of sexual difference
You're Gonna Act Like a Man
what's the matter with you what is the
matter with you you see this now this
story is really something else
a teacher in Canada
uh is uh causing a little bit of a stir
at his school because he is showing up
to class dressed up as a woman with
breasts that are larger than than not
not only larger than the balloons at my
child's birthday party they're they're
probably the size of like four bowling
balls each okay and he has this there
this was not surgically done it would be
impossible to stretch the skin that far
there's no letter I can't tell you it's
a double D or e or F for G there's no
letter it's probably like a double X
okay and so he shows up with this
prosthetic on dressed up like a woman
looking like a complete crazy person
which he is and the students rightly
raised some questions and said hey you
know this is kind of weird right and
there's videos of it going around the
internet and the guy obviously I don't
mean to make fun of the guy the guy's
obviously completely out of his mind and
should see a psychiatrist and probably
be committed but he's now in our in our
insane Society is permitted not only to
kind of run around humiliating himself
and acting like a madman but he's he's
permitted to educate
miseducate students
and then this was brought to the school
and what did the school say
did the school take the side of reason
and normality and the students and the
parents or to the the school take the
side of sexual Anarchy and this Maniac
teacher you know the answer School said
we're aware of discussion on social
media in and in the media regarding
Oakville Trafalgar High School
this in a letter to parents we would
like to take this opportunity to
reiterate to our community that we are
committed to establishing and
maintaining a safe caring inclusive
Equitable and welcoming learning and
working environment for all students and
staff
we strive to promote positive learning
and ensure safe environment for all
students and staff and Community
regardless of race age ability sex
gender identity gender expression sexual
orientation ethnicity
religion
now of course you can't do both you
can't protect the sort of sexual Maniacs
their freedom to do whatever they want
in public and the freedom of people
based on their religion not to have this
nonsense shove down their throats
what does this come down to
this isn't just okay we're going to pass
a law to stop this specific thing you
can only have Prosthetics that go up to
to seek up okay you can't go to double X
okay you can no obviously that's not how
you're going to handle it the problem
here
is that there are protections for what's
called soji sexual orientation and
gender identity
as long as there are legal Protections
in Canada or the United States now we
have them in both places as long as
there are legal protections where you
can't discriminate on the basis of
sexual orientation and gender identity
then you can't stop this because someone
could just say my sexual orientation is
to have like gigantic triple Z
prosthetic breasts on even though I'm a
man and to wear high heels and stilettos
in class and a and a wig that's my
gender identity that's my sexual
orientation and expression and if you
dare oppose me you you awful parents and
students and people with two brain cells
and and a normal sense of things if you
ever Repose me I'm going to take you to
court
and and as long as you have a protection
for this bizarre amorphous category
sexual orientation gender identity
that's what you're going to get the only
way out of this is to repeal those
protections
it they're ridiculous those protections
weren't in place until just a few years
ago because Neil Gorsuch decided to
completely squish on the Supreme Court
and enshrined in civil rights law
protection for soji for for gender
expression or whatever
well what can be done by a rogue lawyer
on the Supreme Court can be undone
especially when it's this radical but
conservatives have to go that far if if
conservatives think that they're going
to solve this problem by just squishing
in the middle and saying okay well you
know your mini skirt has to listen
Mister your mini skirt has to go down at
least to three inches above your knee
then we're not going to win well Mr okay
you can only we've got to approve your
prosthetic by the Bureau of transgender
bras or something it's not going to work
okay you've got to rip this out root and
Branch the rest of the show is
continuing now today is music Monday all
right and so a music Monday the
producers find a song they want me to
give my expert analysis because you know
I'm a big hip Hopper baby I'm Wonder
Mike I've come to say hello to the white
the black the red and the brown the
purple and yellow but first I've got to
tell you to head on over to the member
block today we've got a song
I have not listened to it yet it's a
song by lizzo and so I'm going to give
you my most erudite literary and music
criticism if you're not a member click
the link in the description and join us
we'll see you there in just a second
[Music]
[Music]